this program is brought to you by emory
university dr charles moore is the
co-director of the emory urban health
initiative along with dr. Jada pudsey
gems and the three of us are working
together to build a relationship
inspected a relationship between the
various departments and schools at Emory
and the community so it would be
community-based organizations as well as
people in the community working towards
our calendar now we're very excited
about the partnership because what it
means is that both entities
so the Urban Health Initiative is new we
will be fundraising grant writing and if
there are partners who are interested in
helping to support this initiative for
the improvement of urban health in
metropolitan Atlanta and Emery's
place-based neighborhoods as well as
helping us translate from urban to rural
as we find what works in the urban areas
and similar rural areas we can build
those partnerships the preceding program
is copyrighted by Emory University